raymond brassard est hospitalisé depuis
plus de trois mois
700 monique et son beau-frère pas
l'anglais lui rendre visite
régulièrement dans son fauteuil où il
dormait à l'hôpital saint-sacrement à
québec comme dans la plupart des
hôpitaux
les patients peuvent louer une
télévision raymond brossard ya pensé
mais à cause du prix de location bail le
dit tant pis je la prendrai pause trouve
ça trop cher au québec deux compagnies
privées se partagent la majorité du
marché de la location de télévision dans
les hôpitaux réseau hospitalité et
hôpital en moyenne les tarifs sont de 80
dollars pour une semaine et 180 dollars
par mois sa prochaine
tu peux pas payer 5 dollars par mois les
tarifs sont définis par plusieurs
paramètres à savoir quelle capitale que
ça va prendre pour faire l'installation
complète ensuite question de coûts
d'opération coûts de gestion puis de
l'or on est capable de voir le qu'est ce
qu'on peut donner comme ristournes en
outre une redevance de stationnement
c'est la même chose ils font affaire
avec des compagnies tierces ayons des
redevances qui leur revient dans le
dossier des stationnements des hôpitaux
la cac s'est engagé à réduire les prix
c'était même une de leurs promesses
électorales au québec
les tarifs ne seront pas plus élevés que
de 7 à 10 $ majorée en fonction du temps
qu'on y passera n'est pas de changement
en vue pour le coût de location
télévision par courriel la minus de la
santé daniel mais cannes explique
qu'elle ne souhaite pas intervenir dans
ce dossier
les prix de location des téléviseurs
dans certains établissements peuvent
effectivement surprendre toutefois les
établissements ont toute l'autorité
nécessaire pour la gestion de cette
offre vraiment brassard lui n'a pas les
moyens de se payer les tarifs exigés
c'est presqu'une dépenses inappropriées
pour une personne qui est hospitalisé
parce que ça devient un surplus à payer
un centre speedy ou devrait afrique
c'est le seul auxerre demain le port pas
essayer de faire de l'argent sur le dos
du patient qui déjà il point qu'il rares
sont les hôpitaux petit j'avais même les
services de télévision les nouveaux
hôpitaux montréalais
le centre universitaire de santé mcgill
le centre hospitalier de l'université de
montréal font affaire avec des
compagnies privées
les deux établissements ont refusé de le
dévoiler le montant des redevances
qu'ils reçoivent en retour ici que là
vraiment radio canada montréal